on Monday Robert Clem Cove si.com had a
story that shares a lot of additional
details that weren't previously known
about Antonio Browns legal issues he's
been sued a lot he's got a reputation
allegedly for not paying bills for
getting into business deals he doesn't
follow through on there's also another
woman who has made some allegations of
misconduct not as severe as the
allegations made in last Tuesday's
lawsuit but it's another data point it's
another person it's someone else the NFL
may want to speak to as part of the
investigation that's being conducted
regarding Antonio Brown and at some
point the fact that there are multiple
people making accusations about Antonio
Brown could make those accusations more
credible than they would be if it was
only one person and you know we've kind
of lost sight of the fact guys that
because an Antonio Brown had a big game
and everything seems fine and the NFL
let him play there's still a chance he
ends up on paid leave there's a chance
he ends up being suspended a lot of this
is going to be turn'd determined by the
investigation and only the NFL knows at
this point assuming the interview went
forward yesterday with the accuser
Brittany Taylor who sued him last week
how credible she is how persuasive she
is whatever evidence she may have but we
could find out at some point this week
next week or or maybe not long
thereafter that Antonio Brown isn't
going to be playing football until the
investigation is concluded and
discipline is imposed Peter you know
reading that story yesterday by Robert
Klem Co of one of the things I thought
immediately was because I have said all
along I would never have this guy on my
team never I don't care how good he is
he is a divisive guy and after reading
that story's not a good person and the
bottom line is you know if you get
associated with this guy you saw what
happened with the Raiders now Belichick
can handle anybody I get it so I
understand why he's on their team I
would never have this guy in my locker
room yeah it's just all troubling I mean
it's everything we've heard about
Antonio Brown just kind of coming true
here the last you know 18 months or so
and honestly I'm sick of talking about
the guy because yeah he does not look
like a good human being and it's it's
hard talking about him
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports